so as we alternate our days between
Marvel Comics and DC Comics we're going
to be doing this video is we're gonna be
talking about a character that you guys
I guess a team or a group but you guys
have been asking about time and time
again you guys have been screaming about
this time and time again so what we're
gonna be doing is we're gonna be
answering the question what are the
Celestials and what's their purpose in
the Marvel Universe
so what we're gonna do in this video is
we're going to go with the chronology of
the Celestials not their chronological
comic book appearances we're simply
gonna be going with what we found or at
least what I found to be the chronology
of the Celestials in Marvel Comics so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna jump
to 2013 then we're gonna start with
astonishing x-men issue number 61 now
what this does is give us the Marvel
explanation of how the Celestials came
into existence and what we're gonna find
over the course of this video is that
there's gonna be a lot of contradictions
in terms of the origins of the Marvel
Universe and the model of multiverse
which is going to be one of the reasons
why Marvel is basically rebooting their
multiverse continuity with Secret Wars
and so what we're gonna be doing here
what we find here is that in astonishing
x-men number 61 we're told by saje who
is a mutant that basically has a
computer for a brain more or less that
the Celestials were there at the
beginning of the universe and that they
for some reason or another had created
life in the universe but the problem was
if there was life there had to be death
and so they created a race of beings
some kind of a group that would
effectively be death they would be
destruction and that somewhere along the
way the Celestials had made mistakes and
so what this this group I guess this
this creation was going to do was
effectively destroy the mistakes that
they had made that in turn allowed them
to sort of new but the problem here is
that these beings basically turned
against the Celestials and began
attacking the Celestials and so in
response the Celestials created the
multiverse and in the multiverse they
created a pocket dimension whereby they
stuck these beings in there to keep them
isolated from the rest of existence the
rest of all known creation now this is
our first contradiction because the
question is how can the Celestials be
the at the beginning of reality if we
have beings like the one above all what
was the purpose of the one above all
before the Celestials came along more so
than that if you recall our discussion
about the Infinity Gauntlet we had
talked about how according to Thanos and
his fit I guess is look into the
Infinity well prior to existence there
was one being that was composed of what
would become the infinity gems but due
to the fact that he was basically
extremely lonely he had dispersed itself
among all of all of existence ultimately
creating the infinity gems in the
process
the problem here with regards to the
origin of the Marvel Universe or 606 and
even the other universes is that there's
so much contradiction here so in truth
this is really subject to what you want
to believe if you choose to believe this
is a continuity for how the universe
came into existence that's entirely on
you this is simply just how Marvel's
indicating to us as far as the most
recent explanation of the Celestials as
to how it was they came into existence
now from here we jump to Iron Man the
secret origins of Tony Stark now this
was a terrible story this basically told
us that Tony Stark was engineer the 20s
or had a brother someone is so forth but
the fact remains is that somewhere at
the very early existence of life in the
universe there was another group that
came into existence now whether this
group was created by the Celestials or
not if something we don't know all we
know is that they were simply just there
one day and that they basically gone to
war with the Celestials now this group
was called the aspirants now we don't
actually know what the aspirants looked
like in fact all this really explained
to us in this story is that somewhere
along the line the aspirants had created
something called a God killer armor and
the god killer armor was quite literally
this giant mechanism this giant I guess
the human-like being
that's 225 thousand feet tall and it was
basically used to kill off the
Celestials now what's also established
here is that prior to this war between
the aspirins and the Celestials that
there had apparently been billions of
Celestials Celestials they had been
almost countless Celestials and that's
somewhere along the line once this war
had initiated Celestials were being
killed off left and right and so
ultimately through some form or another
the god killer armor was more or less I
guess defeated or the very least
deactivated then as a result the
aspirants had devolved into civil war
and the Celestials wiped out what was
left of the group now from here we jump
to the actual first chronological
appearance this is the first comic book
appearance of the Celestials and Marvel
Comics with Eternals issues 1 through 12
now this appeared in 1976 and for those
of you guys who are familiar with Jack
Kirby post Marvel when he left Marvel
around the 1970s and when he came to DC
you guys are familiar that Jack Kirby
had intended to launch a series called
the New Gods and to a degree he did he
wanted to create this giant massive I
guess mythology around the concept of
the new
but the problem was that in 1970s DC was
this big melting pot of experimentation
and so a lot of the titles that were
going to go towards the New Gods
mythology were ultimately cancelled off
and when so when Jack Kirby came back to
Marvel Comics he basically launched the
Eternals now what we learn in this 1
through 12 limited series is that at
some point in the distant past of the
planet Earth the Celestials arrived and
they basically found what would become
human beings in terms of evolution that
is to say they found apes that walked
upright and so what they did is knowing
that these Apes would eventually turn
into humans they effectively use the DNA
of these Apes to create two other
societies the first Society were the
deviants and the second society were the
Eternals now the deviants are basically
a race of physical mutants think of them
like a combination between the Morlocks
of HG Wells Time Machine and the
Morlocks and Marvel Comics they mostly
existed subterranean very rarely do they
ever actually have any contact with
humans and in fact a lot of the stories
that originated in the earth-616
continuity and human mythology about
trolls ogres things like that those all
come from from meeting with the deviants
under weird circumstances
now the Eternals were the opposite the
Eternals were nearly genetic genetic
perfection they were basically the
closest that any singular bean could get
to being the Celestials without actually
being a celestial they have a massive
amount of power but the problem was that
as time progressed with the Eternals
they ultimately fell into a state of
civil war and so what we found was that
the Eternals split off into multiple
casts around the earth-616 continuity
which is why we have different versions
of the Eternals we have some Eternals
that protect the planet Earth we have so
many turtles that live among human
habitation on the planet Earth and for
example there are Eternals that live on
the moon Titan of Saturn now this is
where that O's comes into play what we
know is that with the Celestials
destabilizing the gene pool of the
deviants ultimately leading to these
rapid mutations and crazy things like
that we would also have to assume that
somewhere along the line they had
installed the potential inside of
Eternals to become deviance and so this
is the reason why when Thanos was born
he was born with the physical appearance
that he did
Thanos is effectively a mutant on mony
Turtles he is half eternal with a deeper
I guess he's full eternal with a deviant
gene and this is the reason why he is
much more powerful than all the other
Eternals those are the reason why he
looks the way that he does simply
because of the fact that he is basically
a hybrid among his own people now what
we know is that over the course of
Marvel Comics the Celestials have
appeared over several occasions we know
that for example that somewhere in the
distant past again around five or six
thousand BC around the time that
apocalypse was ride into power
apocalypse had come into contact with
celestial technology now the original
assumption and the continuity of the
x-men was that apocalypse had
encountered the celestial technology he
used it for his own ends and ultimately
gave himself this power it's not until
the decimation storyline with with x-men
vol 2 issue number 186 that we learned
that apocalypse it actually borrowed
this technology from the Celestials that
an agreement had been made between
apocalypse and the Celestials that if he
was willing to pay debts later on that
ultimately he could use this celestial
technology for his own ends now of
course we know he failed to pay those
debts we know that at the end of x-men
vol 2 issue number 186 or at least in
this series that ultimately apocalypse
was taken away by the Celestials which
is the reason why apocalypse had
embarked on so many campaigns to gain so
much power his attempt here was to
always find a way to basically stave off
the Celestials bytom to gain as much
power as he did which of course are I
guess as much power as they did which of
course he was ultimately unsuccessful in
doing it now the one thing we also have
to keep in mind here is that the
original coming of the Celestials that
at least as it was given to us in the
Eternals when they first began
experimenting on humans this could be
considered the first host of Celestials
and this is how they appear routinely
they always appear in hosts the second
house of the Celestials came after the
deviants and the Eternals had
effectively been created after they had
reached this sort of I guess expansion
point of sorts and when the second host
of Celestials arrived they began to
examine the planet earth to see how far
their experiments had evolved and
whether or not the planet Earth should
continue to sustain life itself which
again is something that we'll get into
when we find out what happens when
something fails this test but ultimately
when they had arrived the deviants had
immediately attacked the Celestials and
so as a result the Celestials had
basically wiped most of the deviance
from the face of existence leaving only
a handful
left and then left the planet Earth and
so what we found was that again the
third celestial host appears and Thor
annual issue number seven and in issues
number 283 two issues number 300 and
what happens here is that again the
Celestials appear here for the purpose
of judging the planet Earth now the way
that this works they have what's called
a say judging celestial this is the
celestial that arrives on the planet
earth to determine arrives on any planet
to determine whether or not it continued
can continue to exist and the original
intention here of the Celestials when
they arrived was that all life needed to
simply be removed the judge had
basically deemed that the planet Earth
was no longer I guess able or needed to
sustain life and so the intention was to
wipe out all life and effectively start
over again and so in the midst of this
conflict between Thor and the Ascar
diems while they had basically failed in
stopping this Celestials due to the vast
amount of power the Celestials had that
the biological mother of Thor that is to
say mother earth herself had effectively
intervened by simply presenting the
Celestials with twelve beans now these
twelve beings as they were presented to
the Celestials were effectively the
pinnacle of humanity they were the best
that humanity had to offer in terms of
their aspirations their capabilities
they were basically the peak of humanity
in terms of his evolution as far as this
initial I guess implementation is but
with regards to the Celestials and so
the Celestials being satisfied with this
offering had effectively left the planet
Earth alone now in quasar issue number
twenty four from volume one which came
out in 1991 I think around the time and
I believe it was actually part of a
tie-in to the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline quasar witnesses what happens
when a when a I guess a race fails as a
genetic test of the Celestials which
tells us that the planet Earth was not
the only plan of the Celestials had ever
experimented with then in fact the
Celestials had experimented with other
planets and so when he arrives on this
alternate I guess this other planet what
he finds is that the Celestials are
effectively wiping out all life on this
planet entirely it's being completely
eradicated all life is being moved the
entire the entire planets being
sanitized and as a result the Celestials
will start over with their
experimentation again but again what we
find is that for the most part with
regards to this explanation of the
Celestials none of this really matters
none of this is really important and the
reason why is because in New Avengers
issue number 30 what we found was that
basically the the beyonders had wiped
out the Celestials alongside eternity
and infinity and the other cosmic
entities including a Living Tribunal and
so basically all the cosmic entities are
dead nothing really exists now in terms
of the form of cosmic entities and the
Marvel continuity and so again this is
all just kind of leading up to Secret
Wars this is also as part of this
lead-up to Secret Wars we see pretty
much everything coming to an end and the
multiverse being reconciled into a
single reality without being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys on please
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
[Music]